[Music]
in the early 2000s i was hanging outside
of a bar in the lower east side
and uh a couple of kids came up to me
teenagers
and they said are you the guy in the
thing and
and they were very sweet and they
recognized me and i got excited kind of
to be recognized and that these people
were excited it didn't happen to me very
often and i asked them what they did and
they said they lived in the area
and um they were uh interested in acting
and so i said
oh do you do like school plays and they
said no not really we did a movie and i
was like oh
just with your friends and i said well
kind of yeah it actually uh won sundance
and it turned out to be all the kids who
are in the cast of this movie raising
victor vargas which was like a big hit
at sundance and it turns out they had a
much better career than i did
but that was 20 years ago so over the
course of your long illustrious career
how many
sundance winning movies have you been a
part of uh
nearly one whoa almost one yeah
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me is another non-sundance winner
christian i've never even been to oh
you've never done dance you've never
been to the time i've been to utah
no i actually that's not true i have
been to utah for what um and your a
cappella tour in my band oh yeah
and uh i bet you were big in utah we
spent some time you know utah is i think
the most beautiful state in the country
in my opinion wow in the continental
united states oh the the utah shorties
are gonna like to hear that have you
ever been to bryce canyon yes we've
talked about this it's incredible it i
think it outshines grand canyon i think
it's grander the grand canyon oh really
yeah but i've heard i've heard that too
i've heard that
it's more it's beautiful i mean it's
hard to
you can't say anything like negative
about grand canyon but yeah compared
grand canyon grand canyon it's grant i
think bryce canyon's grander
um
why are we talking about canyons and uh
utah oh utah oh
so those kids that i met back then uh
that i um incorrectly labeled as as
being amateur high school actors were
actually uh they were local kids they
lived in the lower east side and they
were all cast members this movie raising
victor vargas among them was our now
friend victor asuke
and melanie diaz who i've since worked
with on a movie that you probably didn't
see called ghost team uh a girl named
ganja that one wins sundance uh i don't
think it even went to slam dance
um but uh victor became a friend and
victor is also
very good friends with our guest today
uh another
friend we're all pals uh and the two of
them know each other from having done
this this tv show uh called
how to make it in america that's right
that was on hbo uh how to not introduce
somebody
uh it was on hbo for two years another
friend of ours brian greenberg was on it
and our guest today uh co-star with
those guys
is louis guzman is it luis or louie i
always wondered that hold on
sorry
you know what i'd like to do i like to
say excuse me before i sneeze did you
have you ever seen me do that yeah yeah
i like it you don't like that no it's
cute
it's your thing that's so me um so you
don't know whether it's louise or louie
you should know by now because it's
louis it's louis it's louis so louis is
not just what people call him who know
him like
you're my buddy so i feel familiar with
you so i'm going to call you louis you
mean how is that name usually pronounced
nic is it luis l-u-i-s his name is
spelled l-u-is
i always i think you might be wrong no
i'm right here's why i know i'm right
because
his instagram handle so sad is louis and
back in the day it's l that's maybe he
spells it phonetically oh really yeah
l-o-o-u-e-y
or something like that
i think that's how he spells it
but back in the day
before i knew that excuse me
excuse me
uh i should i don't say excuse me before
if i guess but um back in the day
i used to kind of
i do this with people whose names i'm
not 100 certain about i kind of just uh
muffled the end of his name i'd be like
what's up dog i know i'd be like
like no i couldn't get away with that no
what's up louise
what's up louie so you don't know it's
louie it's louis all right louie
but i've also heard of luis guzman me
too louis guzman well i hope you get to
the bottom of it in this interview sam
calls him louie and now he's cause he
knows him he's friends with him
oh so you're saying that i'm probably
the nickname that his people who know
him call him louis because it's
affectionate oh they know him but but
his professional name is louis
i think that's probably true oh god i
can't believe i didn't have the last two
minutes of my life back so the people
listening i bet um if we left this in so
luis guzman
is i would say
like the cast of raisins victor vargas
he's like the old the elder statesman of
that movie he also grew up in that area
yes um he's of latin origin he's from
puerto rico for our younger listeners uh
they may be surprised to learn that
many years ago not that many years ago
the lower east side um
did not consist mostly of gentrified uh
rich white people and cupcake shops it
was mostly
uh black and latino uh and louie is what
that was his original hood now that's
offensive calling it a hood well he
calls it that isn't just kidding
i guess it's gonna make you nervous but
luis guzman is a um stop beating around
the bush he is one of our great
character actors yes
for
decades i mean all of those guys in
boogie nights uh he was in some some
iconic
uh character ensemble movies like pokey
knights
yeah the soderberg movies magnolia
that's true god he's that's the thing
these great like steven soderbergh and
paul thomas anderson two of our greatest
and
they cast him in multiple movies so they
keep wanting to work with him so i think
that should tell you something about his
acting prowess but there's also
something about louis that's so i mean
he's very natural on screen but he also
happens to be such a unique
laid-back
personality he's such a
an interesting character just on on his
own as a per as you'll hear in this
interview he um
he is really fun to listen to
so fun to talk to um
and because he's also very
honest he's very playful and sometimes
you don't know when he's playing when
did you meet him uh we met i actually
met him through sam rockwell which is
probably how i've met half of our guests
um
sam was doing a movie called welcome to
collingwood
uh that we'll i think we talked about in
the interview that the russo brothers
did the russo brothers went on to direct
huge marvel movies they directed captain
america now all the avenger movies or
many of the adventure movies um but back
then i think it was their first or
second movie and they had assembled
another great little ensemble in d cast
that consisted of
patricia clarkson and william h macy and
the great michael jeter remember that
actor
did you hesitate because you almost i'm
sorry
yeah that's my thought
one of our great character actors derek
cheater
yeah you never know what you're going to
get that derek cheater is such a
chameleon
bad
he'll be so incredible what he might be
terrible about better than you if he had
one of his arms you think he could bat
left-handed better than i can bet
right-handed of course how can you say
that you don't know what my
skills are some people are really
dominant with one hand with one side of
their body
you have no idea maybe he even if he's
dominant i think one of the worst major
league players
could bet better than you their opposite
hand then you could bat with your
dominant wow you really think that
little of my
baseball skills excuse me no
i i just think so much of being a left
or right dominated person
very few people are comfortable with
both sides of their body yeah but even
if he's like look i know when we throw
left handed it looks ridiculous yes
because i'm not comfortable but when i
throw right-handed it looks great but i
think you're shortchanging a
professional baseball player
anyway um
louise you said louise because i don't
know louis guzman i know him i've met
him a few times yeah you haven't but
uh in new orleans oh of course it looks
like of course yeah it's our second
guest and how many dinner with them at
giacomo's that's so nice and so fun to
go out with oh god yeah so i met him
briefly with sam uh when they were doing
that movie and then i met actually no
you know what i don't think i did meet
him back then i think the first
i think the first time i met him was on
waiting when we did waiting in new york
also in new orleans oh you came off
waiting yeah when i played i played on
waiting
that's what some people say when they
they recognize me from a movie they'll
say oh come off wait yeah did you come
off this movie or that movie it's such
an interesting delivery and i always say
i did come off that
yeah i did
as a matter of fact i came up with i was
stuck to that one for a while
um we talk about when louis first or
louise first comes to the set because we
had been shooting waiting for a couple
weeks and we were all so we we got so
close as a cast it's hard not to and
louis came like i think two maybe a week
and a half two weeks into the shoot he
was kind of like the big star that they
had gotten to do the movie so uh you'll
hear us talk about that funny story and
you'll hear hopefully more that you
enjoy hopefully that's not it hopefully
you enjoy
something oh my god give him a chance
i just want to lower the expectations
hopefully there's at least one or two
seconds of worthwhile
listening um oh well before we get to
the conversation uh i sh we should also
tell everyone that
when louis came into the offices he came
in with his 20 something-year-old son
sammy
who uh could not have been cooler and we
all kind of started going in toward the
booth where we were gonna record and i
said oh um sammy you you'd probably be
more comfortable out there you know just
because it's gonna be the two of us and
talking and louie was like nah man nah
it's cool he can come in like i want him
to be a part of this you know
just know that sammy his son is in the
room um and i wish i knew sammy's
instagram and all that but i'm sure you
can find it on louie's instagram it's
louie from the hood if you want to
follow him um he's really fun to follow
he's been posting a lot of like winter
shots from vermont where he lives uh but
so here is my conversation mostly with
louie and also a little bit with his son
sammy coming up next
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
all right we met doing waiting
how long ago was that that was too long
oh my god like 200 years ago at least i
remember you came in uh we had been
there for a couple weeks and you came in
everyone was we'd been anticipating your
arrival everyone was so excited really
oh yeah you were you're okay
what are you talking about your
presence lent like a real legitimacy to
us being there and doing it when you
came in
we were all trying to figure you out
what's what's louie like what is this oh
really yeah and you were acting do you
remember this you were acting kind of
uh
a little standoffish a little tough to
get to
do you remember this and then you pulled
it was the to this day probably the best
prank that i've ever witnessed uh we
were all kind of on pins and needles and
at one point you just lost it on the
director what the [ __ ] you do you tell
me where to go do you know who i am do
you remember this yeah you know who i
work with i work with stephen
[ __ ] paul thomas yeah and we all
froze
i'll never forget the look on ryan
reynolds massive ryan reynolds muscular
big guy just frozen like bro
some of the girls look like they were
about to cry like oh man he just burst
in my bubble and it's on film they
filmed this yeah oh my god i gotta see
it so check it out so before the movie
came out yeah they showed it oh they did
it like rob posted it oh really but he
only posted the first part
so then he so then i started like
getting death threats and [ __ ] yo you're
my favorite actor you're kidding me
really [ __ ] diva oh they didn't get
it [ __ ] you
like i've been a fan all my life if i
see you i'm gonna punch you in the face
all that [ __ ] so i call rob i said yo
rob you gotta [ __ ] put up the second
half while we come in and we say [ __ ]
april fools
that's the key part so so he did it
and then those people oh man you really
got me oh that's great
i love you i'm sorry that's awesome
isn't that funny how like fickle people
can be they can love you so much and
then they see one moment of behavior
yeah yeah but it was but i remember
thinking i was like one of those people
i was so we were all of us all the young
actors were so devastated because we
loved you we were like you know
you have um
you're
beloved by you know by people and so we
were so crushed we were like oh god
really it was i don't know it was like
finding out there's no santa claus oh my
god gusman's a dick
but it was it was re and you know that
was me and rob
it was all set up and i gotta say rob
mckittrick the director who was in on it
was like it's a pretty good performance
yeah i'm good yeah um yeah in
researching this i was shocked to learn
that you weren't born and raised in
vermont
yeah
a place called puerto rico
that means a lot to me actually yeah
i i am an immigrant
from puerto rico puerto rico you a pr
very proud puerto rican very proud all
my life still do you go back ever you do
you oh i go back at least one sometimes
twice a year oh wow you see your family
there still yeah i got family there and
um
you know sometimes i'll go down and just
do something for the island yeah you
know yeah um that's that's awesome how
so you must have been pretty
involved in the after the hurricane and
yeah well you know we we were
into getting supplies down there and
getting help and trying to help with the
logistics because you know it was like a
real [ __ ] but uh um anytime i can
go down and help out and stuff like that
i'm just happy doing that yeah that's my
people that's my island but i would do
that for any anybody any species
here on this planet so and there there
was with the way you were but you grew
up mostly in new york right in the lower
well i grew up i grew up we first came
to the south bronx oh okay and then we
moved to chelsea oh no
chelsea we moved to the west village and
we lived in the west village from
1960 to 1969. you wasn't born yet that
was like i didn't know that time to be
in the universe
in greenwich village oh my god i bet you
know for real you go and see like bob
dylan i mean that's what i could just
picture those bohemians he used to be
walking across washington square park
and janice joplin and oh once in a while
you know i was a kid you know but we
know the music and stuff because music
back then was so popular you know and
then
and uh so yeah i mean i was a kid but
can you see some of these people that's
so cool would you what was that like
what was that
to see i mean how much new york has
changed must just blow your mind oh well
i mean you know back in those days the
streets were all cobblestone streets
you know what i mean yeah um um and uh
horse and buggies oh yeah awesome
buggies and stuff like that you know um
yeah you are older you look really good
for your age people don't know this
you're 134. you know well bro i really
you wanna you know what the secret is
bro i stopped eating meat
is that true i stopped eating meat no
kidding yeah when how long ago about six
weeks ago oh really yeah i can't tell if
you're joking really is this true i need
sammy i need a confirmation it's true
yes okay that's six weeks ago
and have you
have you noticed a difference oh yeah
bro really the best differences in my
stamina uh yeah yeah more energy oh wait
more energy do you miss it do you miss
meat carne asada uh
the only county i thought that i will
eat is if my mother makes it oh okay you
know i mean i only did this because i
watched that documentary the game
changer i haven't seen and it [ __ ] me
up it was a game changer it wasn't oh
yeah man i mean it just gives you a
whole perspective and
you know uh our food sources yeah
unfortunately are not the best here yeah
so if you go back to puerto rico she's
your mom's in puerto rico no my mom
lives in new york oh okay okay she's 80
years old and she still works at the
hospital no kidding god bless her good
day lord good good for her yeah you so
went so in 69 you moved to the lower
east side
we went to lowe's side to middle class
housing that's what i associate you with
alphabet city town there yeah uh um so
when you say alphabet city yeah those
are fighting words uh-oh because
alphabet cities are what like the
developers started calling
we call it the low east side oh oh oh so
be careful when you call the alphabet
city in front of me i will please in
fact i i guarantee you i'll never do
that you know
what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying
and i don't want to hear like oh sorry
little man that was like three tequilas
in i [ __ ] up and i got a little loose
got a little loose now in that when you
were growing up what was your favorite
starbucks location at the time
my favorite starbucks location i'm gonna
tell you right now was on avenue c
between seventh and eighth street
no man it was a place you go in for two
dollars and 25 cents and you get red you
get rice and beans and either pork chop
or some chicken or beef stew are any of
those places still around i like
esperanza they don't they don't they
don't they don't exist uh the one place
that is still there is a lot restaurant
avenue c
between fourth and fifth street i got
two million steps in that neighborhood
compared to your 20s so i know my way
around
how many siblings did you have because
you have a lot of kids now sammy's got a
lot of siblings yeah um i have uh a
brother and a sister from my mother okay
and two brothers from my father so i'm
i'm like the oldest okay yeah and and
were you with kind of a father figure to
the other ones hell [ __ ] those man
[Laughter]
they have mothers
[Laughter]
they have
what did they do your parents
my mother was a garment worker in the in
the garment district
and my father was a tv repairman in
alphabet city i'm kidding
i'm kidding
i want to see what yeah yeah you're
taking off your uh your bracelets what's
your car park
when you go back to this village now how
do do you miss the old town what's up
bro the best was the old neighborhood
man because i now
is so freaking
yeah they're like cupcake shops it's so
[ __ ] over the a [ __ ] cupcake four
five fifty are you kidding me yeah back
then you get a cupcake in the lower east
cipher you kidding me like 15 20 cents
yeah 450 this [ __ ] better be [ __ ]
magical i know i know you know
louis what kind of kid were you were you
into you strike me as i'm sure you were
still very you're vicarious i was
adventurous i was a hustler yeah you
know um as when we lived in the west
village i was a shoeshine boy oh no you
know i used to deliver food from the
grocery store with the packer
and stuff like that but i was also
adventurous man we would as kids we
would get on the train and go to coney
island oh yeah we would run up to yankee
stadium and sneak into the bleachers
[ __ ] like that oh cool so you were kind
of left to euro you got to like run free
yeah pretty much pretty much you know
because like i said it was at different
times back then you know
and um you know when you growing up in
the west village for example you know we
had the pool we had washington square
park was it dangerous were there were
there dan i mean you have to avoid
certain dangers there well we were
street savvy as kids yeah i mean that's
one that that's one of your survival
skills that you learned first off so you
know where to go and not to go but when
we moved to the low east side i didn't
want to hang out when my parents got
there apart because it was all brand new
middle class housing i want i wanted to
hang in like what we call the ghetto on
the hood yeah and i did you know and
that's where
the [ __ ] was going down you know with
all the drug dealers right there with
some street gangs and stuff like that
and you know hustlers but you know i
ventured out of there because it just
wasn't my thing i mean i have great
friends that i grew up with you're still
close with them oh yeah i i still i'm
i'm friends with uh my friend wayne
and uh we know each other since third
fourth grade wow you know and then i'm
still good friends with people that i
went to high school with wow
and junior has you know so yeah yeah
yeah
how about you you got any friends i do a
few not many high school like maybe one
or two but no it wasn't like that new
york is so concentrated there's so many
people in such a small space that's
right just imagine you had where'd you
grow up in connecticut in uh yeah i
heard that yeah
yeah that's near vermont
um you what so you were you into acting
did you act as a kid no no not at all
bro so the first thing you did was when
you were older when you were uh the
first thing
when i was older
in high school what happened was my gym
teacher
was directing the school play that year
and i was a senior
and so when he was auditioning in the
auditorium and i popped in i always used
to bust his chops in gym class you know
his name was mr egg house but i was
always calling him by his first name
fred
you know what freddie come here freddie
come on man
no push-up today freddie oh [ __ ] that
and what's he chart what did he yeah
what did he find you that charming what
did he like you charming is an
understatement yeah but i'm gonna let
that one go okay you know
he was taken by you well no i mean he
was cool man you know yeah i think he
got me yeah yeah yeah he probably got a
kick out of you yeah yeah so when he was
directing the the play he auditioning
people i walk in and ask what are you
doing so i'm directing the school play
this [ __ ]
bro you can't even run a [ __ ] gym
class you're gonna direct a play
so he took a script and threw it at me
they go well let's see what you can do
so that was a challenge uh-huh and we
don't back down from challenges so i
said son of a [ __ ] okay so uh i said
all right cool i'm gonna do this part he
said you gotta audition no bro bro you
don't understand i'm gonna do the part i
don't know audition oh already right
away
right now and now look at you you're all
distracted
like dude you're lucky to have me here
okay
for some reason i found something you
know that's really fun did you have that
confidence about everything no i don't
know that that because he was my gym
teacher i figured i could get over on
them fred egg house
bread egg house yes egg house
where's that from it's spelled e c
k o o u
h o h a u s have have you seen this
house have you seen him since then oh
yeah i saw him uh
at a birthday party they threw for me in
new york a few years back oh wow that's
yeah he's a lawyer now oh wow yeah so he
went from being a gym teacher so so
anyway the play that i did yeah was
bye-bye birdie and i played mr mcafee
i play mr mcafee my mom did that play
that yeah
really
so you didn't know
did you know that
sammy i did not know this this is all
new to me what did you have to sing in
it yeah you mr mcafee
yeah hear what's wrong with these kids
yeah yeah i still remember the song
and why can't they be like we were
perfect in every way
what's the matter with kids today
well thanks so much you've been
listening to life is short
that's amazing uh yeah you just loved
did you what did you just no no no so i
mean that it was just
something that happened by luck
and i just did it and we did two
performances
and i had fun yeah i got laid after you
know
you know
you know you know you're in the school
play you know of course
yeah then it's like yeah i'm i'm that
guy no that's what teenagers have a
passion about they don't have passions
about acting school plays treading the
boards you know yeah you need to beat
girls but anyway i met you guys on that
uh on and
we are still friends to the to this day
uh uh eddie perez and my boy diego ortiz
and so they brought me to the hood
and there was like this little theater
company in the storefront that they were
a part of so i joined that
so you must have really just loved it
you must have really like taken to it
well well you know i really didn't have
much of a family outside of my family my
own
yeah family and so these guys became a
family like like they helped me to
develop
my first extended family like they took
me
i tell you what the reason
i'm sitting here with you
is because of eddie and diego because
they brought me to the neighborhood i
found
a passion not so much in theater yeah
but more in community activism okay and
that's where that really kicked it off
for me even more and so they weren't
students they weren't caught like uh
students no no we were the three of us
were seniors in high school oh wow wow
yeah yeah they were they were in the
play with me uh uh oh oh and so they
were part of this theater company called
teatro ambulante
and they brought me down and they
introduced me and you know it was
playwrights and poets and
and other actors but you know but
everybody that was involved with this
group was also a social activist oh cool
you know and they still act those guys
no i mean you know um
um a lot of the guys you know fell
victims to
growing up in the neighborhood you know
alcoholism drugs
aids
heart attacks because this is like what
early 70s mid 70s mid 70s yeah so did
you at that time uh you say it's more
for social activism you got into
activism but so did you harbor any like
ambitions to
act professionally no no no i mean um
see but then what happened was miguel
pinero who wrote a play called
eyes yes so
sam told me to ask you
he was kind of part of of that yeah you
know of that oh okay so short eyes is a
play about a prison uh about a child
molester in prison and and you did that
play right you had a i did the movie or
you did the movie i did the movie they
made a movie out of it so mikey
basically put us all in the background
all the guys from the block ah so that
was like my first introduction to film
did you have any lines
um maybe one wow wow like i think that
light was okay
hey that was good but you still remember
all your lines
yeah yeah it was amazing bro it was
amazing
and that was in the so you this is like
early 80s now the movie happens ah this
one movie was in 1975
oh wow okay yeah back then and so you do
that you have that little that
experience and then
you're a social worker right i was a
social worker i became a social worker
but what happened was
it was just a hobby it wasn't something
i was pursuing yeah like somebody would
freaking write something and ask me hey
would you do these eight rows for me
and i would go yeah yeah you didn't have
nothing to do and
you performed four shows and that was it
you know you it's funny you said that
because it strikes me that you still
kind of have that mentality uh you are
so late you're one of the most chill
rockwell said the same thing he said
he's just one of the most chill
laid-back guys on a set
as if it's not
something you feel any pressure to be
doing or or um
this ambition that you have to be
fulfilling it's it's not a hobby anymore
yeah to me it's really become
a real art yeah yeah you know when did
that change louie um i think that
changed when i did q and a with uh
disneyland yeah wow yeah uh that was
nick nolte timothy hunt
charles dutton and that was a more
substantial part then yeah and uh it was
my first movie that i ever did from
beginning to end oh wow you know i had
done crocodile dundee uh too a few years
back oh right he came to new york we
started in australia
yeah they took me to australia holy what
was that like oh my it's kind of like
the lower east side
yeah yeah i mean a lot of [ __ ]
crocodiles just like the lowry side yeah
um
yeah a lot of [ __ ] red ants like just
like the low east side
yeah like you know their version of
cockroaches anyway that's not a bagel
this is a bagel
yeah yeah they had those too yeah
that was really [ __ ] good i'm
impressed oh thanks thank you that was a
good push-up right there kind of [ __ ] me
up a little bit
what was that because that was a big
movie so was that that was huge yeah
well that that bro my first residual
check
for that movie back back in those days
was just producing checks was
substantial yeah and so that was that
check got me my first house in vermont
oh wow now why vermont i i don't think
i've ever asked you that you have a farm
in vermont you've lived there for years
yeah uh we raised llama um
that's amazing sheep in line well i mean
actually lambs
yeah for me and and the llama for the
first uh
yeah so we had like 300 heads of llama
oh my god we had like 75.
i'm just
[Laughter]
all right no i'm keeping count 75 llamas
75 llamas three llamas yeah
i digress yeah it's chickens that i'm
mostly passionate about there we go
there we go no do you have you do have
livestock there though right you have
cows i thought no
no no no we have uh we have a dog okay
used to have horses oh okay we have more
horses than kids yeah i never [ __ ]
understood that how did that happen
i still don't understand yeah yeah yeah
you were [ __ ] there
how many kids five five
why the horses they just got into
horoscope man i have no clue you must
have
some idea
it was a hobby okay it was a [ __ ]
expensive hobby okay anyway so so um so
uh
oh you moved to vermont i moved to
vermont for a bit you know but but um
anyway back to new york yeah go back to
new york before we get to vermont okay
okay what do you want what else do you
want so when did you so when when do you
go from new york to becoming to doing q
a let's say i mean that seems like it
was well it was q a but like i said you
know i i did crocodile done the two so
you were working consistently so that
then i did q a and then right after that
um
i did khalito's way oh yeah what a great
movie and that because i kind of
you know because everybody loves a good
[ __ ] gangster movie there's brian de
palma yeah
pacino what was that champagne john
leguizamo you want some more water no no
i'm good okay what was that like what
was it because were you i i had no
[ __ ] clue what i was doing bro but
you've done these that you had done
these other movies you worked with cindy
lumet and you worked with paul hogan
you work with crocodile dundee yeah but
the drugs were different man yeah okay
all right
you know yeah it kind of kind of makes
it hard to remember no
no no no but i i tell you what man when
you're at a table reading
and your idol is two people away from
you this is crocodile zandy no this is
al pacino
[Laughter]
what was that like
what do you think what are you feeling
you're a young actor you're i don't have
to put a shrimp on the bottom
pacino was supposed to do crocodiles
yes yes that's not a knife
yes very good
okay what's that like louis you're like
sitting there with with not only patina
but [ __ ] sean penny yeah yeah but i
was
very intimidated that's hard to believe
you know yeah i can't imagine you then
right just for one day though yeah yeah
just for one yeah you know and then what
happened how'd you ease into it i call
one of my buddies who kind of
works with al reading helping him go
through materials he loves workshopping
stuff
yeah so i asked him about you know
uh al and stuff like that and he gave me
the best advice man said bro you know
this [ __ ] you live in this [ __ ] every
day you grew up with this [ __ ] you roll
with this [ __ ] yeah do your [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah i showed up the next day yo
what's up pal let's go baby oh man about
my nose yeah that's that's really must
have been thinking that that was like
how you really personify
for me that character totally yeah
and it's true i mean like you that
sounds like you were surrounded by that
when you were growing yeah i mean that
was the you know four o'clock in the
morning you go to this a social club
yeah in the back of the room
you know where all the all those
characters hang out you know what i mean
planes around the pool table and
[ __ ] like that and you see all those
personalities yeah and so that that
becomes a study for me that became
studies you probably didn't know it at
the time but you were soaking up these
people you were absorbing their you know
their behavior and their and just what
it was like to be authentic i i was
living the life yeah you know because i
was i was like that also life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
um
do you remember what inspired that
character he has so much bravado uh that
guy but then when he gets to act in a
porn scene he kind of like shuts down
he's so clearly uncomfortable was that
was that all in the scriptures
i think that was um a very repressive
yeah part of the story yeah you know
because like they did not let this brown
brother get some uh-huh do you
understand yeah oh so there was so they
like so they like my switch did not go
on
my mom my switch were ready yeah but
they turned it off
yeah you do you know what i'm gonna do
you understand yeah you want me to get
more no no i see they uh they yeah i get
it i got you yeah you could you couldn't
rise to the occasion i could have
yeah
[Laughter]
i love that guy i also love your pants
in that movie you wear these um oh my
god bro polyester
oh man you know you hike them up too
that's amazing i forgot
that i used to wear that [ __ ] back in
the day when i did the wardrobe video yo
people used to wear this [ __ ] yeah and i
kind of yeah dude you are this [ __ ] oh
wow yeah that's right yeah it became
kind of comfortable did you like my
wardrobe in that movie i love i loved it
it came up to your belly button [ __ ]
yeah that's how it was but yeah that's
how you roll uh what was paul thomas
anderson like well he's you've worked
with him a couple times now paul's great
you know paul very [ __ ] passionate
you know his mind is always going you
know um
how would you describe like the you've
worked with paul and steven soderbergh
they put you in three movies each i
think yeah that's how you know you're a
great actor what are what makes them
different what are their different
styles i mean you know well look paul's
a writer yeah you know so that's one
thing that makes him different
but but steve is also on his side he's
also a cinematographer that's right he
shoots them himself right yeah so you
know you got two different things yeah
and a high level of talent going on so
that's what makes them different but it
also makes them great at the same time
did you
doing boogie night had you seen hard you
were in well no i was not in harmony oh
man i got to tell you a story about that
oh yeah yeah so we went to a screening
of it
and i'm sitting in between paul
and mike the luca oh boy who ran new
line at the time yeah so i'm sitting and
watching the movie and it's like a
little slow for me or i have been out
a lot
before you were a little slow for it
yeah yeah yeah you know what i think
you know so
so i literally started falling out oh no
at one point i started snoring
right now and i heard myself all
i woke up and right looked over the paw
and he's like yo what the [ __ ] had he
already cast you in boogie nights oh yes
oh but you didn't shot it oh my god my
god yeah that's really funny did you
explain to him like i didn't explain
[ __ ] oh that's funny that's funny were
you but you hadn't shot the boogie
knights yet
no that's fine no are you thinking oh
[ __ ] he's gonna no but you know what i
think i explained that i'm sorry paul
like not my you know
something i you know i don't even know
if i say anything but blame it on china
i just know this i never brought it up
again
until now never oh
yeah yeah you know we're recording this
oh
but i was waiting for you to see no no
no sorry i should have given you the
green light what uh yeah that's all
right are you kidding me we can start
from i thought you were just [ __ ]
warming up
i'm sorry oh my god okay
uh i got to ask you about then
so do you remember anything else from
boogie nights that i hate when these i
know i feel like i'm one of those
interviewers i hate like tell me a fun
story from boogie nights but do does i
love that movie so much i know it so
well
uh do you have any memories that stand
out so one night we were shooting it was
night
and so
julian moore and myself
we crossed the street and we go into a
dive bar
because they told you you know it's
going to be a while to set up yeah so
julian moore and i go into this bar
and we stop playing pool and we're
playing pool for a while and [ __ ] like
this
you know
we lost track of time yeah i think maybe
we had a drink or two i don't know
you know we're like just totally
chilling yeah then all of a sudden the
[ __ ] pa walked in and he's all sweaty
and everything he said yo man we've been
running around looking for you guys
and we were like dude we were [ __ ] 20
feet away
you know when we came into the bar
that's right they freak out you're gonna
you they freak out if they can't find it
so that that that was pretty cool and
then another time um
uh um um it was really cool
because uh tupac came through oh wow
yeah
because you know him and mark are good
friends oh i didn't know that so he came
by and that was really cool hey did he
was he did he know you yeah yeah yeah
yeah we were really cool oh man you know
that and then um of course working with
like burt reynolds and stuff you know
what was he what was that like
burp was uh interesting man burt was
like i'm gonna be at burt wasn't the
challenge
you know he kind of
came in with that whole i taught iconic
status you know
i mean i i don't know i mean he was yeah
you know what i mean but he carried
himself up he carried himself iconically
yeah yeah yeah very good good work yeah
good work but um
but uh uh um you know he was he was cool
with me yeah you know mainly cool with
everybody else but you know him being
iconic he always got to give
the wreck the [ __ ] yeah so
you know but he got through it he got
through it and
what was that shot that great opening
shot um
that it's sort of reminiscent of the the
goodfellas shot that steadicam show
where they go through the club your club
right how difficult was that to
choreograph how how much time did that
take to set up we shot that no we
rehearsed it
the whole night before i think you told
me that actually we did not shoot
anything i think
we rehearsed it wow we rehearsed the
moves first and then we started
rehearsing with the camera wow you know
and like it was a it was a major
choreography yeah i bet which was
phenomenal because yeah so the shot
starts
that's a crane shot the guy's on the
crane the camera's on the crane
and the crane comes down
you know follows the car the guy goes
like
running down the street behind the car
the car comes in the guy runs onto the
sidewalk so now he's looking at them
getting out of the car right pull the
camera
and then we go in and then the camera
follows so somebody grabs the camera
from the crane and they they passed it
off
no no the guy was on the stage oh yeah
yeah wow on the crane he stepped off oh
wow
yeah he stepped off and he started
running and this is back in the day when
steadicams were pretty heavy yeah they
were much heavier so we rehearsed that
the whole night i bet and then it was
the next night we came back rehearsed
half the night
and then we probably got our first shot
off at like three in the morning
and we ended up doing maybe six seven
takes and that was there that was it wow
you know it's pretty crazy that that
mike deluca um it's pretty amazing that
he financed that movie they don't make
movies like that anymore no they don't i
mean um it was an incredible cast yeah
oh my god like outfit molina
you know that part where where the guy's
going oh the firecrackers that's that's
yeah it's chinese well you know you know
what they they uh
they had to get me off the dude man
because he showed up to the party and i
that's that was the one character that i
despised so much i said do you got any
firecrackers
no
[Laughter]
i was like this is another farm story
isn't it
so you know and
do you know going in that it's going to
be something special a movie like that
do you go into that movie um you know
you you got
you have a good vibe yeah yeah you know
you you see
you know they're really taking the time
to make the look right to the lighting
you know
this is the takes that we need yeah
there's a chair getting taken you're
getting you're getting you know you
speak with your director he speaks to
you you know yeah i mean so all these
things you know was there a lot of
improvising or was it pretty scripted um
it was pretty scripted but loose yeah
you know i mean like that whole thing
with me and don shiro with the telephone
and stuff
yeah great when you when they call
looking for julia yeah yeah you know um
but
it's all pretty scripted and
and the stuff at the pool like put me in
the mood come on i can do this you know
i can oh yeah you keep appealing to be
in the movie yeah yes
yeah oh it's great you know uh some that
julian moore story kind of reminded me
of something that sammy
rockwell told me about he said you gotta
ask louie about um doing welcome to
collingwood uh which is the movie i love
which the it was directed by the russo
brothers
uh and the russo brothers before they
got into them you know now they're
directing the biggest movies in the
world [ __ ] don't call me either
yeah me either
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i hope
they're listening [ __ ] yeah man yeah
so which one do you despise more anthony
or joe oh gabe good question thanks
you're right up there baby you're right
up there no yeah yeah no so so it was
funny so when we were working on colin
was so yeah so another great cast so
yeah so anthony will come up and he'll
say something to me and then
and then he walked and joe would come up
and he would say something to me so then
then they call then they go call row
and then yell out so which one guys
which one you want me to do oh were they
different directions yeah
oh it's funny it was too funny yeah it's
cool that was really nice guys uh no no
but they were great yeah they they you
you saw they had they had a good
chemistry working with each other you
know uh-huh
sammy told me that it was uh it was the
first time he'd ever been to a baseball
game that you took him to a baseball
game i did yeah do you remember this
you went to a cleveland indians game
that's right yeah and he was uh amazed
that because he was like it was a lesson
for him he said because he was so um
worried about having to go to rehearsal
like this was a sunday and you
apparently you were like hey man chill
it's sunday let's go to the game you
know you were just like that's how sam
was struck by how chill you were he goes
it was a real lesson for him and then
you went to the rehearsal afterwards it
was fine yeah yeah yeah
that's cool yeah i know i had i had fun
time with them
like i said it was such a great great
cast of people yeah it was a fun movie i
was just really disappointed because you
know i felt like they never really
distributed that movie correctly yeah
it's and it's right it was george
clooney who no he he produced it he did
i mean are you trying to say it's his
fault maybe probably yeah yeah i blame
everything
i have to call him have a talk with
george um george if you're listening he
is probably let's talk buddy yeah he he
keeps trying to get on the show and i'm
like
i'm still waiting for that tractor
george
yeah yeah is that a that's an inside
thing between you and george yeah i
shouldn't have brought that up but you
know now well just putting it out there
you know you're airing all your
grievances now this is the reason this
is a good place nobody knows where we
are undisclosed location that's right
they'll never find us
a bomb shelter no don't say that
what is it like um
another uh duck incoming
uh you don't have to worry about that in
vermont right you know what about the
apocalypse and end of days because you
guys will be safe first of all we don't
really think about it up there or you
don't yeah yeah it's so big on somebody
else's plate
how how much time do you spend up there
are you there most uh as much as i can
yeah you know as much as i can then uh
it's beautiful yeah you know it keeps
you active you know because it's like
you got a farm um this one spot i have
127 acres you know what yeah i know
every [ __ ] tree
you have 127 acres yeah you know how
many trees
i don't know but i'd like to know
a lot yeah
so one is born every a bunch of the
bunch of born like every spring right so
you got to go back oh you're brand new
hey come here give me a hug
you name them all uh
yeah can you would you mind just naming
just listing all their names timber
timber one
timber one three four
timber
uh hey what uh what motivated you to
move there
why did you move through oh man i moved
there because um well i love vermont it
was just a nice place to go chill you
know when's the first time how did you
discover when's it first well um i was
like i don't know i was 17 18 years old
and one of my boys was a professor there
and he got some scholarships for some
guys from the neighborhood
and so that gave us a university of
vermont uh uh goddard college okay uh
david mammoth went there macy went there
no kidding the band fish started out of
the barn there nowhere that's where i
was hanging baby all right
stuff with the lab the labyrinth because
they have a i know summer program up
there at in in in bennington in
bennington right bennington college
did you do plays with them is that
how do you no no no i i just went out
there to hang out yeah yeah yeah i went
up there to hang out and and where'd you
meet victor rasuke another victor oh the
way we met victor asuke is
i watched the movie
saving victor vargas [ __ ] vargas yeah i
thought it was raising victor raising
victory
raising private
yeah although i was tentative in my
defense yeah you sounded pretty
confident did i yes
but you go to the end faster than i did
that's true without confidence
so i i saw that movie i was blown away i
said oh my god i got to meet this kid
yeah victor and melanie diaz
and they all grew up in
in the lower side so um i called my age
and said uh you i want please give this
kid my number i want to okay so he
called me up and i said hey man i just
want to
really thank you for that performance oh
wow that must be so spot on
and stuff like that and you must have
loved that yeah you know because like
you know sometimes you see something and
you have the
opportunity to go beyond just
appreciating it yeah but also giving
somebody that props
must have meant a lot to him yeah
because like i said he did a great job
yeah but also to have like the whole
cast i'm sure to him you're like an
elder statesman you're somebody that he
i'm sure i'm not that [ __ ] know bro
like an elderly i didn't mean elderly
statesman
an elder you could just call me a hero
yeah okay here could be
then you guys ended up working together
on uh how to make it in america with
another good buddy of mine brian
greenberg yes i love brian pg shout out
uh i gotta bring i asked victor what to
ask you about i said i told him i was
gonna be doing this and uh he said the
victor said ask him about how we almost
went unconscious because we both knocked
heads by mistake in the middle of a
scene
while shooting that [ __ ] how to make in
america do you remember this yes very
clearly
very [ __ ] clear how did that happen
you know so so this was my way of
teaching victor something i said i know
you an actor [ __ ] but now
i gotta step it up to the next level
here don't [ __ ] ever anticipate the
[ __ ] okay
let it happen because what happened in
that take
he anticipated the move and he went
first oh that's funny yeah what was the
move
you know just go right past me uh-huh
you know
and and then and then and then he
decided to start on his own and by by
the time we and then he moved and he
just
[ __ ] it up he said he said he had a
knot on his oh yeah he had a [ __ ] nah
he said the size of north texas [ __ ]
yeah
he still got a little bit of that [ __ ] i
think he had to get plastic surgery
getting to stand it down or something
yeah well he was no but i i love working
with vic he was fun man he was he was he
was out of control in the best way yeah
i love that guy and and uh to shoot in
new york must have been close oh yeah it
was great yeah yeah you know i mean like
like i said the great thing about that
character renee
it's like
you kind of
you i understood him so well because
i know people like that and i've been
and they had some of my elements there's
a hustler element yeah yeah yeah you
know and like dealing with the [ __ ]
guys that i was dealing with and [ __ ]
you know
oh my god you know you remember that one
episode when who was it that shot
himself in the foot duffy or mike
mike i said
yeah what the [ __ ] you doing over here
with a [ __ ] gun bro i'm a [ __ ]
ex-felon what's you know
it's like if anybody could [ __ ] it up
for you your boys can [ __ ] it up for you
yeah you know but we it was it was just
a good chemistry and then the show was
such a good formula and it was on for a
couple of years how many years two years
two years yeah yeah should have gone
longer but that's okay you're that hbo
we had we had other things to do that we
were pretty successful that anyway yeah
um
what
i keep coming back to vermont are you
you grew up there sam i grew up there
yeah i grew up in vermont and what was
that like when changing for the world
man it was incredible waking up at 4 30
in the morning thank you so much to do
chores oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean you got to feed the horses
you got to feed the the chickens i don't
remember you doing this
yeah
i don't remember you doing any of that
hey listen this is a narrative that you
can create
people are gonna be listening what are
you trying to say son
but anyway
in the field anyway oh yeah actually
actually we had to hate the fields do
you we had to hate the field yeah with a
butter knife go out there cut that
what do you do when you're not working
um what do i do hey the fields yeah till
till one time
oh yeah we do maple syrup up there
before
that's a metaphor that's a metaphor you
know what is funny is now you grow weed
and i used to grow weed oh really i used
to grow wheat in vermont i don't know
you remember that big dome that we used
to have in sutton that we used to store
all the hay in louisiana if you kept
going
i had like two little plants did you
know not know that oh my god yeah and
now you grow two little plants oh look
at that take it after me i'm proud of
you
yeah you know the basketball field the
basketball court yeah you know right to
the right of the basketball yeah
yeah no [ __ ]
you're just discovering this yeah but i
probably i'm sure i had the better way
i had a better way i had like different
little places i wish i could fight with
my dad about who grew the better weed
this is the dream come on come on man
that's [ __ ]
we said what kind of dad was he was he
strange man not well i mean i mean he
doesn't sound like that yeah you know
you learn your lessons yeah one of the
best lessons i ever learned and i've
taken this i don't know if you know this
i've taken this with me my whole life is
he taught me um i got in trouble in
school in high school a couple of times
and i was freaking out because i think i
got in trouble and it was my dad's
birthday and he had to come to the
principal's office and was like you know
whatever didn't kick that whatever i'm
freaking out and you know he he sat me
down he stopped he said stop crying he
told me he goes you know there's a time
and a place for everything and this is
not the time nor the place let's go
and let's do something else and let's
get figure it out and so that's the
lesson that i've always took women oh
yeah i don't know if you know that i
don't think that was much of a nothing
there's a time and there's a time and a
place yeah the time of the play
and clearly you're in that time yeah
well now fortunately you guys live in a
very um
liberal state i mean it's a very well i
mean i live very [ __ ] white yeah a
lot of white people yeah what is that
like to be the only probably the only
puerto rican from yeah man we well you
know because of us you know there's
still usually a bottleneck in
uh making this decision you know
town projects and [ __ ] no no no i can't
go through there
latino property
that's sacred
what if people how do people treat you
when you're there i mean it's you
probably know your neighbors very well
it's oh no
it's a really cool place man you know
for sure
you know the taxes are too freaking high
well you know what i mean it gets spread
around we love you bernie not enough not
enough but
um but it's a really cool place you know
uh people worked there people hustled
there you know people work the land
which is great people are involved in
their communities um it's very communal
um but not just as a latino but how do
people treat you as a as a recognizable
person there uh everybody's cool yeah
some you know you know like it wasn't a
while you get a character you know
i was in uh tj maxx
right wow yeah
we have we have a few i found one i go
there
so i go to max and this is a couple of
weeks ago you know and uh there's this
guy there and he his head his hair is
like rainbow colors hair
and he got leather and you know he's
like a real character yeah so he sees me
he goes oh my god oh my god so then he's
like starts whistling like
and i'm like and i'm like yo yo keep it
down keep it down buddy whistling yeah
yeah louie just put his
fingers yeah that whistle no and i'm
like yo dude you know
you know and he goes is it really you
and go who are you talking about you
know because i try i try and this is how
i'm trying to like
uh deflect yeah yeah
are you the actor guy i said what ask
the guy you talking about tom cruise
[Laughter]
that's a good one i'm gonna have to try
that i like doing that so anyway so
anyway the guy goes away and then he and
then he's like still whistling and he's
going
to his girl because it knows
he's trying to get her attention yeah
you know she has no teeth and [ __ ]
remember
it's easier for her to whistle oh my god
so
you know um um um but then you're like
just just chill like like tj maxx so
then he comes back and i kind of feel
like a little bad for him you know
he goes
he goes you go dude i mean you make my
baby tell me you're that guy like oh i'm
that guy he turns around
bro you got to cut that
i'm that guy and then he goes can i take
a picture
all right come on okay quick bro i got i
got shop i got a shot they take a
picture he walks away whistling
that's so weird
that's such a weird thing a whistler an
obnoxious whistler yeah so anyway but
it's not unless you make somebody's day
i bet you yeah yeah and and i i you know
[ __ ] hell yeah why not yeah i mean it's
cool there's no it's not taking up any
of my time you know who is that guy for
you louie growing up like if you had met
him somebody in tj maxx not that you
shot when you're a kid but
what i thought i think it would be walt
frazier oh yeah
yeah back in the day clyde yeah i mean
we saw him the other day and you got
pretty giddy yeah oh really really
excited about that hell really yeah
do you like him as an announcer uh or or
a basketball player better uh basketball
player yeah how did how often do you go
to those games
once a year yeah
yeah couple times a year maybe twice a
year yeah you grew up loving the knicks
that was your time oh yeah right yeah
right now it's
it's a tough love situation i know
aren't you very
tough
oh really no you saw some good you saw
charles oakley and ewing era i didn't
see oh i mean i must have been little
when you ain't yeah
yeah
so knicks and and mets
or yank yeah
yeah yeah
thank you bro thank you sorry yeah i
wish people could see this louise now
glaring at me
[Music]
hello hello
you've done so many different parts many
different ways is there a role that you
haven't done that you
think about doing that you want to i
want to be a superhero with a conscience
oh man you know what i'm saying what you
were a superhero weren't you in mr uh
okay i wanna hear mystery man right yeah
which one mystery man no mr man no i
feel like you were you did that i was i
wasn't mystery man but i was not a
superhero oh okay i was a [ __ ] hot
dog bender oh
my god
but a heroic hot dog veteran yeah i'll
do my research again giving the brown
brother
right hot dog hot dog yeah
yeah
yeah so uh so we can put it out there
now you want to play a superhero is
there a particular with a conscience
okay
who is your favorite superhero out there
man if the russo brother is called
which they should
um cato
cato cato okay kato kalyn
no bruce lee bruce yeah
[ __ ] kid okay all right uh what
we should do account we should do
we got to do another movie together then
what did the movie we did we did two
which one waiting and remember to look
alike both shot in new orleans that's
right what what is your do you uh do you
love going back there tonight um well
forget that yeah i think um um i would
love to do a movie with justin i would
love it and that's just two [ __ ]
scenes yeah i know [ __ ] i know
and um and we're shooting new orleans
again we
don't want to shoot in new orleans with
you and vermont you know not vermont you
know
maybe we should head up to like montreal
oh that's great montreal i've never been
i'm dying to go i've never been here
it's right up here just come visit us
and then we'll drive up to montreal i
would love that i would actually love
that yeah yeah montreal such a cool
you've never been in montreal
how could you not go tomorrow i don't
know i don't know i know you grew up in
[ __ ] connecticut well you don't have
to judge me you don't have to come out i
mean
well that is the most high you've been
hostile several times
you know passive aggressive baby yeah uh
are you were you do you grew up with
religion louis did you grow up
um catholic my mom was catholic yeah she
is catholic i was baptized in the
communion
and [ __ ] but um my mom used to send me
to church she wouldn't go i don't know
oh really hilarious she trusted you to
stay there he said mom how come you
don't go come to church with me because
she goes
with
i used to get in so much trouble i mean
she made me she made me an altar boy oh
i was an ultra boy i mean it was like
something
it was like crazy no kidding yeah i was
drinking wine and like sick [ __ ] no
that's funny that that louis that she
and your dad was your dad into it
um my dad never went to church i never
saw him at church huh but they would
make you go not only make you go but
make you be yeah right yeah do you know
that same thing no a lot of stories that
you're getting oh yeah never i'm just
like here like just listening yeah yeah
yeah i tell you what my mom this is how
bad i was yeah
how bad were you
third grade
cub scouts
yeah gave me three [ __ ] months to
remember the earth
okay
i promise to be loyal
trust trustworthy yeah
you know and then then like i stopped
making [ __ ] up
i used to improvise that's when you were
like yeah you put in your improv skills
yeah man oh yeah so so you know to be on
time to be uh good at yeah wake up in
the morning you know yeah not not eat
all the not eat all the cakes you
urinate in the toilet and not in public
for three [ __ ] months you know yeah
and i can't get this oath down
so finally
finally
you know it's still like okay this is
your last chance
you know and i'm doing it i'm doing it
and there's like ten of them and then i
get to number eight
and then i get to nine and i [ __ ] it
up my stomach just [ __ ] it up that's
so they said that's it you can't come
back oh really yeah
i felt like really dejected so the it
was
so
so it was hooked up you know directory
to the church and there was a courtyard
so instead of going out to the front
i decided to go to the courtyard through
the church
out into the street so i wouldn't have
to walk around
do the walk of shame but when i go into
the church
thank you mm-hmm the walk of shame um
it's a cub scout term yes
so what happened i go into the church
and i go to the door that leads to the
street and the [ __ ] door is locked
it's a deadbolt lock right
like okay [ __ ] it but then i go back and
i try to go to the door that i came into
and that was the dead bulldogs now the
door just stacks behind you yeah you
can't open it
so here i am
you know
10 years old 11 years old stuck in the
[ __ ] church it's at night
it's pooping oh my god
[ __ ] you know
it's like jesus is gonna get me yeah you
know there's not a priest in here
somewhere hiding out
you know what i'm saying yeah and uh so
i started knocking on the door to the
street
and finally somebody stops and i'm like
yo please i'm stuck in here so they came
to get me finally after like an hour oh
my god like [ __ ] crying oh god
it's a good place to pray yeah it's
ironic that you yeah please don't let
jesus get me yeah so you know my mom she
came and they told her what i did and
and uh yeah that was it that was it for
your cub scout so [ __ ] that no thank
goodness you didn't make us do that oh
that's so funny yeah well it's probably
because i would not have
known yeah not after that experience no
way
you know what i mean i made
oh you did so that's how you discovered
you you were next you didn't grow up
with uh surrounded by nature or anything
oh that's a good point maybe that's true
that's where it came from your love of
of it's outbound we're outward bound
no man
i grew up in the [ __ ] west village we
used to go upstate all the time hang out
as kids oh you did yeah bro so why did
you join the outward bound program
um it was part of my leadership training
thing that that i was a part of that
your friends got you into yeah uh oh
sorry i i um i did out with bound
i did the institute of um
the ecumenical institute
in uh
chicago i did three years of college in
two months what i took a course like
that oh my god i'm hearing all these
stories for the first you didn't know
that i didn't know a lot of you know you
know i think that's really [ __ ]
because because i i think you've never
really you're just just listening yeah
you don't listen yeah
now you're sort of forced now he got
choice yeah you're captive audiences
[Music]
[Music]
so that's why you so you encouraged him
to do the or you made him do the outward
brown program because of the the
experience well you remember the story i
was telling you about in regards to the
life lesson yeah and getting in trouble
in school he gave me a life lesson and
now wow well very intimate thank you
megan megan just turned off the two heat
lamps oh yeah we realized uh and now
how's this is this weird that it's dark
it's completely dark i feel like we
should have a lava lamp
i think they're gonna be listening to us
in the dark now okay i don't think they
could tell the difference though no i
didn't sound darker for the audience
um okay well this is good because now
now you can't read your [ __ ]
these are quick this is like lightning
round okay as much time as you want
the last thing i would want to do is
hold you back from from anything so uh
no bro you got me what's the most what
is your most and i think i know the
answer to this what is your most
commonly used emoji
i'm glad i can't see because i i think i
i don't you know i'll be honest with you
i i don't have one that's what i thought
that's exactly what i thought who the
[ __ ] has time for that a lot of people
not me sam he doesn't use emojis can you
confirm this i yeah he has he doesn't
use emojis yeah good yeah it'd be weird
if you did actually it would be weird
yeah because then they would call me a
millennial yeah yeah do you do you sami
i do i have one mine's the one with the
eyebrows uh
do you know what i'm talking about yeah
one is like hmm
you have one uh i usually do
i did i totally i got instagram i
totally succumbed okay it's like i
follow you on this yeah yeah yeah thanks
for following me oh you do yes oh good
okay okay let me right here
believe it or not this is lightning wow
by the way the only answer was there was
no and i'm the one prolonging it if you
could be a professional athlete uh what
sport would you play
baseball yeah
for
the yankees
uh
i would play for uh
i probably would just play in puerto
rico oh okay yeah i mean i wouldn't mind
playing for the yankees but i played
with them for a couple years but i head
back to puerto rico and play for that
yeah what are the charities are there is
there a specific charity that you're
working with in regards to puerto rico
now
um not really i mean it's pretty
independent okay you know if there's an
orphanage that needs to be painted
you know somebody needs the roof and
stuff like that and somebody needs a job
and yeah and culinary and stuff like
that i mean so we we've done
little bits here and there and that's
the nice thing about instagram too that
people can find that information out on
yeah okay uh if you could have one snack
food a snack food that you're you're
you're stoned you're you do you get
snacky when when you smoke yeah yeah
okay
louie is stroking his uh beard and
staring at me seriously you what is your
go-to snack food uh i like i like uh a
peanut butter wafer
covered in chocolate
ah a peanut butter wafer i don't know
that i've ever had that but we only have
them in vermont it's a vermont thing wow
this is such a great this is just going
to be like a long advertisement for
vermont
come to vermont yeah the best maple
syrup the best peanut butter wafers
chocolate chips great weed
cheese
yeah and tons of latinos and
latinos
uh what is your favorite movie of all
time
on the waterfront oh great yeah that's a
good yeah and just do you have a
favorite that you've done the one that
you when it's on time
i have quite a few i mean uh
you know kalito's way was great boogie
nights uh the limey
creases you know
punch construct love is great
monte cristo you know so yeah yeah i
missed phil i had quite a few yeah we
talked about phil hoffman what's your
favorite movie of yours
no no of yours
uh
i that's a good question i don't know i
you know i
i think that's closest i'm not even here
[ __ ] answer yeah no i would say
galaxy quest just because it was my
first one it was the one that that's
where i met
sammy and i got to work with alan
rickman and that's just uh you know
it was that's cool uh if you could live
somewhere else anywhere else other than
vermont where where would you want to
live
uh probably want to live um either in
puerto rico or in barcelona oh barcelona
um well also never been there uh if you
could have dinner with three people whom
you've never met uh dead or alive who
who would you pick you'd have a nice
dinner uh
marlon brando
uh martin luther king jr
and um
and uh don pedro campos
god i'm embarrassed to admit this
i don't know who marlon brando is
no i don't know who the last person is
uh he was a puerto rican nationalist he
was he was uh
he was a fighter for our people
back in the 40s and 50s and
and uh he was tortured by the cia and
giving radiation
dosages and that's how they came wow but
god but he was a nationalist you know he
stood up for our people sammy did you
know that didn't make me feel a lot
better he was a doctor good he was a
doctor
um he took care of people for free wow
you know he was just saying he was but
he was also a fighter you know on behalf
of justice those will be the three
people good dinner oh it's a good lineup
um who's your favorite muppet i know
it's a tough there's no way to make that
transition oh uh for me i i gotta say
it's a cookie monster oh that's funny
people have been saying why not why
why yeah because he's [ __ ] crazy and
radical yes he's crazy all over the
place yeah okay
nobody nobody reacts like that everybody
is like hey
yeah he's just like he just smoked a ton
of weed he's good yeah man there you go
i feel that way sometimes and i always
used to freak me out with it frustrated
me what was your favorite uh i loved
beaker and bunsen honey do i love their
relationship a swedish chef made me
laugh more than any other
who was your favorite ernie ernie oh
barney from ernie and bert okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah give me like all those
yeah yeah love them
but with cookie monster it always
bothered me that uh so much so many of
the cookie pieces didn't actually go
into his
mouth like what are you doing they're
just falling right in front of you
upsetting
um if you could have one super where we
were talking about uh being a superhero
with a conscience if you could have a
superpower in life what what would it be
my super power yeah
oh man my super power would be to change
people's minds
in what sense uh into
in whatever sense i wanted to change oh
okay all right bend them to your will
and okay if that's how you want to sound
sinister i put a sinister spin on it
you had to know yeah but i'm a nice guy
so you know
like a lot of nice things will be going
on you are i will say okay everybody
salsa
and everybody will start doing that
that's great yeah but okay everybody
sleep
everybody sleep
there be a break everybody get funky
if i get funky and go stop and they stop
you know like that yeah yeah yeah like
that so you i would love to vote for me
vote for me
you know what i'm saying like that
uh are you bernie sanders guy i was
wearing the sweatshirt you met um you
know right now um i am a bernie sanders
guy yeah you know um good i'm gonna
leave it at that um thank you yes okay
uh if you could be uh reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you be
i would like to be
uh i like to be an eagle
an eagle i just like to fly around and
check out the scene oh yeah
how about you sammy i think a red panda
why red panda because there's you'd be
so endangered ye that's true you know
you know you just yeah you're not gonna
have to be up in vancouver well eagles
are endangered that's true eagles are
indeed not in vancouver
well there's a surplus of it yeah man
eagles in vancouver don't kidding me i
got bigger the litter up there
a red panther red panda red pandas yeah
not much company there
uh which might be nice you have it all
yourselves you have all the the bamboo
yourself
some sort of monkey i think
i like monkeys
monkeys are [ __ ] up i want to tell you
that [ __ ] right now i know they're i
mean i wouldn't be
you know [ __ ] that monkey yeah i
wouldn't be
there's a great viral video of a monkey
trying to have sex with a frog have you
ever seen that one no
check
um well you know you look up frog sex
and that and then monkeys leads to
monkeys and they suggest that yeah i i
can't wait to see that whale on that
seal
uh dogs are cats i think i know the
answer dogs yep okay hey do you have a
dog now you said we have a yeah we have
a blue nose pit
oh cool yeah who knows
what kind of food do you cook louie you
strike me as someone who cooks i don't i
do cook yeah
what do you go to what's your you want
to impress somebody you have marlon
brando's coming over
well what am i cooking for marlin
yeah i think with spanish rice and beans
yeah that's not good maybe
sammy did he get you into cooking did
you cook uh i cook on special occasions
uh-huh i cook them very bad like when
he's [ __ ] hungry
i love like my favorite thing i love
cooking breakfast um like it's the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] everything what is it
scrambled eggs with bacon no that's not
a bar
that's when other people are making my
food when i make my food i do i go all
out well now you can't now he can't have
the bacon anymore is that that's right
that's the show and i can't cook for you
oh you you
and i couldn't cook because you're vegan
that's true i can't call your eggs
because
i could do coconut
flour pancakes oh wow blueberries in
there all right well now i know
i haven't cooked thanksgiving i made
some apple pie vegan apple pie what is
it
so no butter no no butter
uh no butter and and um no
no eggs no eggs
[Music]
that's good
that was popping bro wait so louis
you're so i didn't know you were vegan i
i thought you were just like had stopped
eating meat yeah that's hardcore that's
tough stop beating me and it was it was
all about like an energy level thing um
you know sometimes you just gotta change
your lifestyle and
and you know our food chain here in this
country you know
you just gotta be more and more careful
what you eat and it was this movie that
motivated what was the movie called the
game changer the game changer on netflix
yeah i have not seen it yet you're like
i want to keep eating i want to keep
eating meat i like bacon too much i will
check it out but i'm still in the prime
of my life so i'm gonna enjoy it for a
little bit longer that's true and then
and then i'll do it wow that's intense
that must have been a really compelling
movie
it was it was it was um what are you
what are you working on now are you
working on a movie now um i'm putting a
movie together with this young man i'm
um putting uh uh we got this book called
bodega dreams written by ernesto
quinones and uh
we're looking uh to finalize um the
financing of course and okay if you need
any sort of
scrawny
white nerds oh yeah okay you know what
you know what so
there is a great role in there of that
i'm listening so so um
you just signed on to it okay
i oh yeah
and i love bodegas yeah
and i love you this is all it has the
makings of something that is easy to say
yes to uh beetle the beetles are rolling
stones beetles yeah okay
was no a no-brainer um and do you think
about
your do you think about things like
legacy how you want to be remembered
what um
like what what you would want on on a
gravestone or something you're really
pushing this age thing no no i asked
everyone that sammy yeah yeah i asked i
was gonna ask you right after
oh your days
your days are numbered uh what do you
hope to do um yeah um um sure yeah yeah
why not no but like it a is it a
something you think about like um when
you you think back about your your body
of work how you want to be remember well
um
for the little while that i am
remembered as a good person yeah
yeah well as a good artist uh
yeah i made people laugh well you know i
showed people i was down to earth yeah
approachable
all those except for the guy in t.j.maxx
yeah man um well i i couldn't agree more
with all those things i i can't thank
you enough doing this you're one of my
favorites actors and people so this was
a treat yeah and i appreciate being here
and i'm very proud of you justin thanks
thanks this is really sweet
[Music]
so
yeah that happened
that was good
um he's so fun
oh my god wasn't it funny to hear him um
i started we started picturing him as a
cookie monster when he was like nah
because oh my god cookie monster what
does he say he's crazy why do you like
cookie monster he goes
why because he's crazy and radical
and he is he's just
so honest him saying certain things made
me laugh so hard just hearing them come
out of his mouth like the word oath
at one point he says uh he says
[ __ ] oh laughter fun
philosopher
is one of the greatest voices i've ever
ever heard in my life i know that's why
you want to do something you want to
like think of a great idea i know to
capture
him i mean not just his voice but his
whole essence he has his look his whole
uh you know we were talking about energy
is so it's so unique i think it's so
special christian i've been wanting to
write something for him for many years
and
we had an idea at one point and then we
were talking about doing an animated
show with him and but then it's like
because he's got such a great voice as
we just said but
he's got such a great face too to go
along with it it's like you don't want
to like
you want to get you want to capture this
is a great presence yeah yeah uh that
prank that you referenced in the intro
when you first met him when he came to
the set of waiting and he that must have
been such an effective oh my prank
because
first of all it sounds like you're
really committed to it he was mean and
he blew up because
he does have kind of a scary potentially
scary
look oh my god potentially he's got a
very scary intimidating look yes yeah
well that's why he's so laid-back and
friendly but let's say he wasn't let's
say he was a huge [ __ ] and he had
that look he would be one of the more
intimidating human beings i you know you
could come across yeah and that's why
it's interest he's interesting because
he had he does have that look but he is
such a nice person he's such a even his
answer about like what superpower would
you want and to make basically make
other people nice like he just he lives
in vermont he's like a sweet family man
he's the the person that he is i feel
like runs very counter to what you might
think of him based purely on his
appearance and the characters that he's
played i mean he's played real
he started his career playing mostly
yeah yeah yeah did you get scared when
you called it alphabet city instead of
lowry's side yes he it sounded like he
got yes he's a little serious about it
it's hard to tell when he jokes because
he's so dry
i think he was serious about that though
you're right it is i think so too i
think he was like don't
it it's like he
really resents what happened there
understands
yeah so he doesn't like that term and i
represent somebody i had a place in the
lower east side for a while i i was part
of his the pro you know quote unquote
kind of but you weren't a
rich developer who came in and no but i
said but i supported that by buying
something there by by being you know
spending money in that gentrified area i
was part of it totally that's true in a
in a building that was
developed and right now and like kind of
an eyesore i i love you to tell them
this me too i know me i lived for a
while and it's called the blue building
on river uh rivington oh my god that's
right that was the lorry side that's
like
i know i felt really guilty
that i supported that but now it's funny
i bet i bet there's so many i remember
when that building when you first
bought a place there that building was
like such an eyesore in a sea of like
authentic now i bet there's a lot i bet
that kind of um fits in now but that
building i bet there are other buildings
like that down there all the worse all
the worse that i supported that because
that probably opened the floodgates for
other developers i know
i'm glad i didn't tell him that uh but
you're right it's but maybe he's
listening now it's difficult it's very
difficult to know he's joking like when
he talked about his farm which i do
believe he has i don't think he's joking
about that no he definitely does i've
seen pictures of it but when he said he
has llamas yeah
and
by the way he could have easily had
llamas that have i well then farm in
vermont he was like yeah like 75 llamas
then i started thinking 75
llamas is a lot of llamas so he's
probably joking does he have that lawn
for that many llamas stupid and his son
was like his son was like
he started laughing and giving it away
then you're like oh i thought you had
this livestock there at some point
he's like nah nah and he's like well i
used to have horses and you're like oh
so
wait
what's the joke
is that yeah no it was it was um really
misleading when he was like yeah i also
got cows
and it's like wait do you have casey
he's not nah not cow i'm kidding about
that but horses it's like oh but you
just so you have some like beasts of
burden
you have like cloven hooves animals
there you he talked about not eating
meat anymore he gave up eating yeah at
one point you asked if you missed meat
and you tried to connect with him and he
goes and you go do you miss eating meat
like carne asada i knew your guy
well i just think because i remember him
no you know why because i remember him
saying how much he loved his mother's
that wasn't just purely like a shameless
attempt to like like a patronizing
attempt
um it was mostly that i guess it was it
was a cool story about him first getting
into acting when he did the school play
with the gym teacher oh my god he's just
like wanted the challenge he like didn't
like the fact that i i i kept picturing
little louis guzman and louie yeah i had
little louie so how funny that must have
been his life he was talking about is
the gym teacher slash
uh director of the show called
fred egg house yeah and you're like a
house egg house and he's like yeah
and
then he goes
yeah it's spelled like e c
k
h a u s and you go oh eckhouse and he
goes yeah egg house
i started picturing
little louie was so funny to imagine
because he
i he just must have been a little like
energetic like confident bowling ball of
a kid and but i was picturing him with
like a big you know because he grew up
in the
late in the 60s and the 70s when that
and like hair was really big i just
pictured him with like a big like fro
and one of the like a little whiskey
mustache can
it also makes sense that he was given he
said like
as a kid oh yeah they must be doing all
these odd jobs and shining shoes and go
oh people must have loved he must have
people
charmed by him yeah and that's why also
probably why he seems completely
fearless now
yeah he never cultivated any fear he was
never in that was never instilled in him
it sounds like yeah he seems like he was
always although he talks about that one
day the first day with al pacino and
yeah one day of fear one compared to a
lifetime 4 000 days of fear that i've
had
yeah it's funny though that's why i was
like what did that look like because
louie to me seems like the epitome of
confidence like he just seems like so
we were talking about this like the way
he answers those questions he never
seems to like be concerned with how he
sounds or well like when he answered the
question about the dinner what three
people you want to play with he there is
no concern for
uh
what's a good answer yeah how can i make
this sound good
i think a lot of people
want to want to have good answers
they're at least like somewhat aware of
like not that his answer wasn't good but
yeah there seems to be no awareness for
how is this going to come across what
are people going to think of me he
doesn't seem like he has any of those
hang-ups no and maybe he does but it
doesn't seem like it it doesn't show and
that's why i was so curious about that
one day he talks about with pacino like
what does because i've certainly never
seen that what is like an insecure or um
a louis without confidence look like
what does that look like i wonder how
that manifested and
it's crazy that imagine being able to
instill that in somebody that's that's
the power that somebody like pacino has
yeah but then of course the next days
his friend gave him a pep talk the next
day like that went away yeah you are
this person which is such a good thing
to remind
him like
i mean for for any actors but most
actors aren't didn't grow up that way
most actors don't have that authentic
and upbringing they you know certainly
not a lot of them there's something real
to tap into totally yeah uh you singing
bye bye birdie with him was amazing that
was a highlight of
like my time on this podcast like my
i've had a really i've had a few like
really great moments that i've like i
can't believe i got to do that thing
with leah thompson and there have been a
few moments on this podcast and i just
feel really lucky to have had but that
that's got to be up there
you know that scene in boogie nights
i've seen boogie nights when um
it's one of my favorite scenes it's when
the whole so he plays his character
who's who's the restaurant owner he owns
this restaurant that they all go to and
he has this bravado
jack
he's so big and gregarious and he's
always trying to get a scene in a in a
porn movie and but do you talk to jack
thompson put me in the movie he's like
desperately yeah and it's long story
short he ends up getting in a movie and
you see uh like a one quick scene of him
in the movie and he is
to me i've always thought that he
it was a choice that that he made that
his character finally when he gets a
chance he's going to kind of be scared
and barely be able to get the words out
that's how i've always read it but yeah
did you notice it was interesting he
said that that's not how he was playing
it he was playing it like his character
couldn't was capable of really going for
it but he was being kind of neutered
because he was they're not going to let
the brown guy oh yeah so it wasn't that
his character got scared and clammed up
when the cameras were rolling it was
that
he felt like they didn't they didn't let
him oh see i didn't i thought maybe he
was just saying that about the character
like they made him he couldn't he kept
using like innuendo like i could like
but i couldn't like get a i couldn't get
a boner i read that as he said they
could but the filmmakers in the
fictional movie
kept him down oh okay well that's what i
think
oh okay well that might be true that
must be true maybe not maybe i missed
maybe i misread it or maybe i just
misunderstood what he was saying maybe
let's see what the audience thinks okay
um you uh
you pretending to remember that specific
how to make it an america episode oh
yeah i never because i didn't he was
like he's like remember that one with
tony was that the dodge i had to say
yeah and you're like oh yeah i did say
yes in my defense i didn't say yes i was
just like ha ha
oh yeah
i think i just left
um
fun through a fun through life i'm so
glad he didn't stop and be like wait do
you remember that he's like oh yeah then
what was the name of the guy who
our our thing about how to make it in
america and
again two of our very good friends are
in it so now of three including i saw a
bunch of those episodes i'm sure you did
i did two i just didn't remember 10
years ago no although what's your
impression of how to make it in america
my impression of how to make it in
america is
yo we gotta sell these jeans son
we got
we got all these jeans brian greenberg
being like yo what are we gonna do with
these jeans and victory suits like yo i
know someone who's going to move these
jeans for our son
and then there's louis like i'll say you
want to sell these cheese i i help you
savage jeans
okay it's a really good impression um uh
there's a through line throughout the
interview where you kept trying to
understand why he lives in vermont and
you kept asking in different ways and
you're like so when did you start
i couldn't get it out you're like oh you
did an
outward bound program and that was
that's right and he was like nah man
i grew up in the west village i and we
went upstate all the time you're like
okay so it's not bad
and then his son even his son was like
yeah i didn't know that like i didn't
know how you developed this
it's still to me you know a mystery why
louis guzman
lives on a farm in vermont he's really
cool i talked to him for an hour and a
half and it's still a mystery i don't
get why he does well it's really cool
that he does it's cool that he's it's
also like i'm sort of glad that i didn't
get like a straight answer and it
there's it only adds this
for to me only added to louie's mystique
and louis has like
more than most actors especially in the
days of like in the time of instagram
and social media
where where like any sort of mystique is
goes away with like a few posts and
people are always showing parts of their
lives but louis has still such a
mystique to him you know as does like
john c riley and some of those other
boogie nights guys yeah phil had that
like
that there's not a lot and so i like i
kind of like that
right that you still don't know why
in vermont i know it we've had dinner
with him and he never really explained
it wouldn't be as fun if it was like oh
his wife was from there and they ended
up buying yeah they inherited atlanta
piece of land yeah he just likes it he
likes it there that tj maxx story when
he's um it's also funny he's going to tj
maxx in vermont yeah and he's being
confronted
by guys with rainbow colors keep
yeah isn't it funny
to hear louis i mean hear louis say
anything but here louis call some other
guy a character he was a real character
man
and it's like i guess well what it takes
to be a real character for him you have
like rainbow colored hair cheers
everywhere yeah and yeah it's girlfriend
and no teeth
that that story of him as a cub scout
getting stuck in the church is so again
because you picture little like bowling
ball like high hair
like little kid louie uh he's great his
voice is so unique and he's such a funny
great laid-back personality that even
when he tells a story that like
maybe isn't the best story it's like
a story that maybe doesn't have like if
you saw it in writing and be like oh
okay
like the story it's still entertaining
like the story about uh julianne moore
mm-hmm and when they were shooting play
united well played pool basically he
just went
to he just went and played pool with
julian they couldn't find the pa
couldn't find him for a few hours like
however long
that's the story it's like if anyone
else told that it'd be like
yeah okay he could read the phone book
and i would be entertained i know i know
uh it was funny at one point you were
like because he was talking about how he
got into acting it was basically he fell
into it he was he was doing social work
and then he was doing little side
projects as a hobby
and
and you tried to make a point which i
thought was
seemed astute where you said oh you know
it's kind of like you have this energy
on set where it's almost as if
because you're not that ambitious
that it's almost you treat it like it's
still a hobby and he was like nah man
now it's like my profession and i felt
immediately stupid i don't mean it like
that
because in the wrong kind of it sounds
insulting
i know you didn't mean it that way of
course not he has so much respect for
his abilities of course he's one of my
favorites but he carries himself
like it's just something he likes to do
and he's not aggressive or pushy about
it well it's a thing that i brought up
that even that rockwell told me because
i'd seen sam the night before and he was
i was like what can i you know do you
have any like funny inside
scoop about louie and uh because they've
known each other for years and
he told me that story the anecdote about
him going to a baseball sam's first
baseball game with louie and uh that's a
show oh that's that i'm in mine
okay any sporting event any sporting
event but when kasam is such a dedic i
mean they're both dedicated actors but
they just approach it so differently
like sam's thing was like
we can't miss rehearsal or like or be
late to rehearsal or anything like we
got to be working on this thing and
louie was like
hey man it's sunday it's sunday man like
chill out and that's what sam's point
was like louie's the most i've heard
this from other people he is just the
most
chill like he's the most chill
especially for an actor and an actor of
his stature to be like
nah man this is back this is a early
this is like two that you're two
thousand years almost twenty yeah it was
20 years ago uh he's the best it really
is the best it was yeah i
i can't like i know i say this for other
guests but like louis does not have to
do a podcast louie is like a legend
louis could just stay on his farm in
vermont and raise
us
i'll read a letter okay
uh this is from chrissy a the subject is
wanderlust life greetings justin and
christian i said it that way because
there's an exclamation point at the end
first off i am loving the podcast
thank you
i appreciate the guest conversations and
laughs you share with us that's very
nice
life is indeed short and completely
unpredictable i grew up the small town
girl next door hey me too
traveled what what you didn't know
traveled worked hard and graduated uc
davis
with my dream career in wildlife biology
life was my oyster and i had a plan for
success
a tsunami of health issues
including a broken back god and divorce
from a first responder later i'm not
where i thought i'd be but that's okay
i got a reality check on what's really
important and for me it was reconnecting
with my family i'm a beautiful work in
progress and now find gratitude in all
things for anyone struggling to adjust
to whatever life is thrown their way be
kind to yourself and do the best you can
each day justin i would love to hear
your guests take on the best piece of
advice they've ever been given that's a
good question you know we should start
incorporating that yeah um
also please do a podcast with dan
aykroyd oh that'd be great that'd be
great
rogan had him on and it was amazing
well
rogan uh has
a little bit more reach than we do but
uh dan aykroyd would be amazing i i know
him a little bit from
the hit film the bafta winning
crossroads that didn't go to sundance ah
surprisingly no i think they were aiming
directly for cannes
thank you for making me smile at my
phone
[ __ ] it and pull it cheers oh chrissy is
her name so
yeah so you can edit later um chrissy
thank you that's that's good advice
really good advice for uh asking for
advice that's great that's a good point
we should start asking you we do every
once in a while yeah what's the best you
can give your younger self that's true
we've done um and dan aykroyd would be
great awesome to have he is i remember
uh hanging out with him a little bit at
that um at the wrap party for that or
whatever one of those crossroads events
um
and he was he's really into like
uh motorcycles and he's he's got that's
his whole aesthetic is like uh he's got
this what do you call it like uh what
hell is harley davidson yeah
harley-davidson type vibe oh really
that's surprising did you know that yeah
he had like a
yeah that's how he dressed and he had
that like one of those leather vests
that kind of thing that that's sort of
surprising it was to me at the time um
well i'm glad chrissy you're pulling
yourself up because that sounds um like
you had a tough go for a while but you
know being positive and trying to find
silver linings is uh that's what you do
i also like you have to keep going i
like you know i've been
advice advice that we give to kids i
think is still so useful and that sounds
like something that you know
my younger more cynical self might have
scoffed at like dude when she says do
the best you can each day it's like
okay sesame street like that but the
older i get like the more i've invested
in some value and value yeah yeah do the
best you can
playing value simplicity
uh so thanks chrissy uh chrissy a and
thanks luigi
what a what a character true character
one of our greatest characters
and uh we were so lucky to get him to to
agree to appear or to what do you say
for a peer when it's just your sound
your voice um i your i think your voice
can appear no oh can oh no maybe not
we're agreed we're glad he agreed to
lend his voice yeah lent his great
great voice
never heard a voice like that no and i
probably never will so thank you louis
for your voice and for your uh your
kindness over the years and if you guys
want to write in
um our email address is life is short at
wanderie.com we love hearing from you
yeah okay now here we are petering out
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short it's hosted by me justin
long
it's produced by christian long
and megan monaco
our senior producer is michelle miesh
lance
and our audio engineer is
sergio enriquez
executive producers are marshall louie
and
ernan lopez for what wondering
bye see you next week
[Music]
i'm in tampa with louie and uh you just
listened to him what do you think yeah
man i just want to really thank
everybody for listening thank you justin
i had a great time with you also with
sami and uh everybody should listen
there because this is really special
because you're special and i'm special
to me special and you can't get no more
special than that especially it'd be
tough it'd be tough but listen it's a
good podcast well hopefully they have
listened because this will be at the end
okay be there or be there
you